un peu de tabac et quelques morceaux de
comté Stéphane mermillot Anselme lui se
fait des joints au fromage
j'ai décidé de d'alterner de faire une
semaine un reportage sur des gens un peu
normaux bien et tout et puis la semaine
dernière la semaine prochaine et une
semaine un reportage sur un vrai allumé
et cette semaine j'ai fait un reportage
sur un véritable allumé et vous allez
voir qu'il est très très spécial et tout
ce qui dit il le croit quoi et c'est
étonnant et il le bois éventuellement
ouais il le mange
tout est bon pour se défoncer suffit d'y
croire un peu de tabac et quelques
morceaux de comté Stéphane mermillot en
scène lui se fait des joints au fromage
le joint coule et lui touille un peu la
cervelle il sent venir l'extase alors il
s'exclame
cette lueur il vient du réchaud et
arrive les premières hallucinations
[Musique]
sur un fourneau se prépare une potion
Stéphane chante la fondue savoyarde
pendant que les montagnes dégoulinent à
l'horizon il a déguisé sa femme en vache
il la trouve mieux comme ça il sait
aussi construire un attaché-case a fondu
pour pouvoir en faire partout j'aimerais
bien pouvoir en faire en survolant
lesquatteurs dans une tribu en Afrique
stéphane est le seul type que je connais
savoir faire une fondue dans le TGV ils
ont rien dit les contrôleurs au
contraire les deux contrôleurs ont mangé
ils étaient très content on a bulle
blanc et tout c'était super Stéphane
fait aussi de la fondue dans la rue je
mange la fondue dans la rue pour me
faire plaisir et les gens qui
s'approchent leur propose un verre de
pinard et je leur offre un morceau de
pain mais Stéphane est triste souvent
les gens refusent il n'aime pas tremper
le morceau de pain avec des inconnus ils
ont peur du sida c'est pour ça que qu'on
a développé la raclette et pas la fondue
les industriels ont inventé un appareil
à raclette à plusieurs compartiments
chacun a sa propre casserole chacun a
son propre microbe et personne n'embête
les autres alors Stéphane cherche
d'autres débouchés à la fondue il essaie
de créer un masque de beauté pour sa
femme mais ça marche pas très bien à
cause des grumeaux
par contre il vient d'inventer un parfum
dont il est très fier et voici également
le parfum fondu alors je m'en mets pour
aller dans les night club le samedi
c'est redoutable je t'explique pas la
gueule des meufs
c'est la nuit Stéphane redescend sur
terre il est vidé comme un caquelon en
fin de repas alors il s'endort sur ses
rêves de fondue et de communion
universelle Stéphane c'est quoi le
bonheur
on est tous là à plongé son bout de pain
dans la même marmite on est on est face
à face et puis et puis on s'amuse bien
[Musique]